dunque la mia associazione facilita la
città una nuova civiltà nasce da una mia
esigenza di rimanere uno spazio di
convivialità con altri ricercatori dei
diversi interiori io sono stata
dell'ultimo tanti anni a fare dei
percorsi interiori delle ricerche
interiori e poi dopo tanto studio dopo
tanta sofferenza volanti sperimentali
nel 2012 un momento di grande confusione
ha detto adesso fermiamoci un attimo
mettiamoci tra un litigio don carlo
davanti un buon teatro buon bicchiere
siamo insieme non siamo più nel
efficientismo dello studio dell'inter
apprendimento dell'andare a scavare
siamo semplicemente qua vediamo se siamo
capaci di percepire che cosa ci è
richiesto in questo momento è dunque
questa associazione facilità organizza
cene principalmente da tre terroristi 16
per i nuovi paradigmi quindi facilita
raccoglie intorno a sé gente che si
occupa di stili brinda yoga ci sono i
curiosi che sono professionisti
artigiani imprenditori e commercianti
ci sono quindi sorbo dell'ecologia che
si occupa della economia etica che si
occupano del nuovo paradigma che
costruiscono nuovi eventi
i nuovi modi di stare insieme e non ci
sono quelle persone di schioppo della
tecnologia spirituale delle ultime di
videoarte consentito quell'antica ci
sono gli sciamani ci sono quelli che si
occupano della daytona terapia della
curia oltre 3 miliardi
ci sono quelli che sono dei molti che le
gestioni che sono integrati access i
pennelli per essere un po tutti così tra
gli istituti abbiamo cristiani cabalisti
buddisti susy eccetera
nello yoga avremo il tantra del pd per
cdc lerici pur nel nell'arte avremo
l'arte terapia il teatro la danza
terapia io stessa sono mente niente in
casa del vento identità arrivato il
bisogno della vera dunque quasi sap ogni
singolo individuo viene qua solo al suo
attivo a monte di questo link
questa esperienza che nasce in gennaio
di quest'anno
osservandola che cosa mi ha insegnato
che siamo tutti soli in questo momento
ci sentiamo che non mi sento di sé
malissimo ma lettera sono tutte stelle
parliamo tutti da trovare l'interruttore
per accedere da nostra stella
io oggi voglio farne un piccolo regalino
per spiegarli dove lo trovate di un
interruttore
non so se conoscete i discorsi tipo di
mezzo ci sono gli schiavi delle case
farmaceutiche i naturopati di sonno
ciarlatani gli sciamani ti fregano i
soldi
lasciamo perdere le donne gli uomini
perché sennò i poveri sono invidiosi i
ricchi sono sfruttatori
no non so se sentite emozionare i suoi
aprire queste parole a queste case
quell'emozione nel punto in cui vuole
sentire quella il costo 12 interiore e
quello che tiene la guardia del vostro
interruttore quello che può accendere la
vostra luce interiore
adesso in una civiltà in cui i soli non
sono più isolati separati ma sono stelle
che sono ognuno unico irripetibile il
solo e unico essere così ma nello stesso
tempo uniti brillanti ognuno sa che le
coste
nel momento giusto sta succedendo
esattamente una cosa che doveva fare la
cosa da cui renato che tipo di società
avremo intanto non c'è più limite che la
competizione conflitto quando
ricominciamo dal parte dalla nascita è
dovuto essere una sua naturalezza non è
più la malattia
allegri danza il partente giuridica
disabile non c'è bisogno di particolari
vissuto il suo animale guida nel suo
edita nel suo colore è già il suo
debutto non verrà messo in una fabbrica
di cervelli con uno standard di
educazione con una formattazione
dell'educazione uguale per tutti ma il
suo punto del privato con la gita acqua
con la giusta dice quella giusta terra
con la giusta alla temperatura e quindi
gli adolescenti cioè la povertà ognuna
di queste cose perché ce ne trattata
nascita all'infanzia il passaggio
dall'infanzia all'adolescenza e sarà una
tela delle celebrazioni pubblica in
maniera individuale
quindi si recupera tutto quanto su un
senso di un 12 a tibia e non ci sarà mai
più pd che questo è meglio di quello
perché questa persone della terza in
maniera diametralmente opposta anni è la
mia ricchezza
io ne ho veramente bisogno sono fiera
sono felice di essere suoni canti si è
fatto ai denti che quest'anno in questa
società di tutti quanti grida definire
tutto dal defunto età discusso reti
facili giovane automaticamente non avrei
bisogno di essere dipendente di qualche
cosa perché avrà le porte aperte perché
tutti vorranno sapere quali sono i suoi
denti cosa mi sta portando il vecchio
non sarà più in là sarà colonia dall
esperienza
è una nota bellissima archeologica
eppure cioè non ce l'abbiamo più in
tutto questo tutta questa cosa fa
civiltà offre questo modo di stare
insieme per il momento di puro affetto
del momento di vedere che c'è il medico
ci sta lo sa ma non c'è un angelo del
nostro della nostra prima posizione
abbiamo veramente moltissimo quindi in
questo momento quello che io sto
cercando nuove e semplicemente qualche
anno ci possediamo ci mettiamo 12 di
suona quella casa una diversa memoria è
come dire questo conto ma che noi stiamo
così commentato abbiamo sentito
attentati contro di loro
dov'è che noi stiamo giudicando e
giocandoci dunque in questa maniera
io posso dire adesso tutti quanti
veramente buon lavoro stasera se volete
tutti contate qualcosa c'era in casa
milan